okay so uh let's start with a little bit
of the collusion between big Tech and
big government because we've all known
that this has been going on for a while
we've played this a clip of Jen's sake
former White House Press Secretary Jen
saki many times where she flat out said
that the administration was flagging her
words flagging posts for Facebook
related to disinformation about covet
that's pretty much as close as you can
get to a First Amendment violation at
least as I see it well now here is our
new White House Press Secretary Karin
Jean-Pierre asked about White House
emails with social media companies and
it does seem that they've been kind of
colluded when it comes to your speech so
a federal judge talk about the social
media lawsuits from Missouri and
Louisiana federal judge ordered that you
have 20 days to turn over emails of
communicating with social media
companies every misinformation and
disinformation
um what are those emails going to show
what kind of things so I can't comment
you've asked me this question last week
I can't comment on any specifically
ongoing litigation and so again I'd
refer you we would refer you to
Department of Justice as we've said over
and over again since the beginning of
the administration in our battle against
covid-19 it has been critical for the
American people to have access to
factual accurate science-based
information on information
so it's pretty spectacular what she's
doing there on one hand she's saying she
can't comment on anything and then the
last sentence there she's basically
saying but you know we clearly do this
have a little bit more from the New York
Post the Biden Administration worked in
tandem with social media giants like
Facebook and Twitter to censor
statements they deemed misinformation
about topics including the kobit 19
pandemic two Republican state attorney
general said on Thursday as they push
for the release of emails between top
executive branch officials and big Tech
Titans in a petition filed Wednesday in
a Louisiana Federal Court State Attorney
General Jeff Landry and his Missouri
counterpart Eric Schmidt charged that
dozens of federal office officials
across at least 11 federal agencies
engaged in a massive sprawling Federal
censorship Enterprise with the intent
and effect of pressuring social media
platforms to censor and suppress private
speech that Federal officials disfavor
the the Attorney General said they have
ident identified at least 45 people
within HHS and the Department of
Homeland Security who have communicated
with social media companies about
misinformation all right Robert to you
first you are my official lawyer here at
the Reuben report or unofficial or
something like that but if a government
let's say the United States government
the federal government talks to these
social media companies and they get as
close to saying hey we're going to shut
you down or we're going to break you up
or you better do this or something like
that what is the point where this
becomes an actual violation of the First
Amendment which as everyone knows who's
watching this it's about government
censorship but they're they're really
pushing that line right
uh no doubt I mean if you go back to the
Bantam Books U.S Supreme Court case that
that Case established where any
government agency is using any coercive
tool to uh to basically censor speech at
any level is a First Amendment violation
now the problem is the federal courts
have been reluctant to extend that
Doctrine to the big Tech context uh one
of the main cases that's going to be
deciding this issue is the ninth circuit
case involving Robert Kennedy his suit
against Facebook on the grounds they
were acting as a government agent and
his reason for believing that was based
on just a little bit of the information
that these two attorney generals have
Unearthed by filing a lawsuit
challenging what's taking place what
this discovery exposed and there's more
Discovery to come the judges ordered
fauci to produce all of his
Communications and all of his staffs and
teams Communications uh in within three
weeks by the end of September and so
that will probably provide even more
revelatory information it was clearly so
rattling the big Tech that Zuckerberg
went on Joe Rogan and said oh by the way
the FBI is the one who really told me to
suppress the hunter Biden laptop story
he knew this was going to be coming out
in some capacity anyway but this is what
we've long suspected it's just once the
bite Administration took over it became
systematic and institutionalized and
it's across all agencies not just the
Department of Homeland Security or or
HHS they found evidence of it with the
FBI they found evidence of it with other
government agencies basically government
agencies that have extraordinary power
over big Tech with those high-ranking
officials not low-level people doing
what the disinformation governance board
was going to officially informally
coordinate had already been informally
occurring for for the entire Biden
Administration and this should be a
First Amendment violation the question
is whether federal courts will step up
to it and recognize it as such under
existing precedent so Robert just on the
legal side before I jump to the other
guys is the issue here I mean I watched
and I'm sure everyone that's watching
this saw at least some of the clips of
Zuckerberg on Facebook and he never flat
out said hey they contacted us and they
said we're going to break you up or
we're going to use antitrust legislation
or we're going to send Regulators in or
you know you know open your books check
their algorithm that basically they got
a call like oh there's some stuff going
on we just kind of want you to know so
that's what makes this tough to to
really go after somebody right because
they get as close to that line as
possible without moving over it exactly
they've been playing this game where
they they'll say hey I really hope you
could help us out here and then maybe
next week they say way as the White
House by the way did this week maybe we
need some big Tech reform and we need to
take away your immunity or and escalate
Anti-Trust actions so the message is
clear big Tech knows what's happening
and the key is for courts to acknowledge
and admit that this is the implicit
reality but they're playing a game by
not making it explicit in Express
I'm like you guys at Prager you know a
little something about being suppressed
and there have been lawsuits against
Google and YouTube and all of that stuff
I mean are we basically at the point
where for any of us that do something
like this for a living we just kind of
have to just put our hands up and be
like hey we're on these platforms and
just until we're not and and that's it
or or they'll just censor us to the
point that we think we're doing
something that people are seeing but
they're not really seeing it right I
mean it's a tough line to walk there I
hope these lawsuits are successful in
their Endeavors but like you said we're
no strangers to this sort of censorship
we've been dealing with it for a very
long time I think the video that we got
taken down that really sparked us
engaging in a lawsuit with Google was a
video about the Ten Commandments being
taken down and censored by prageru so
it's it's unbelievable it's something
that I unfortunately am not super
optimistic about I feel like they have a
pretty synergistic relationship between
big Tech and the government and they
don't want to see that relationship
disbanded yeah this is like you know
will no one rid me of this meddlesome
priest you know when Henry II wanted to
get rid of Thomas Beckett it said that
he didn't give the order to have him off
he just you know mentioned in the
presence of his Knights that this is a
guy that he would really like to see
gone and lo and behold of course then
you know you've got a basically a
paramilitary force flocking to
Canterbury to get this guy out of the
way it's exactly what's going on between
the big tech companies and the
government and I think it really gives
the lie to this ongoing kind of shrug
that we get from some quarters that oh
these are private companies they can do
whatever they like I mean Dave you sort
of mentioned this and I think we need to
recognize that these entities are not
these little like Plucky garage startups
as as Robert were saying you know that
they don't just kind of come along and
sell you their product and their
products really great and oh well if
they want to kick you off they can kick
you off I mean this is these have been
buttressed by government funds
government uh you know blowback for
years and years you know Google has been
entangled with the FBI and the CIA and
it shouldn't come as a surprise now that
we're seeing that these deals are going
on you know more and more in public
because these companies have really
become a kind of Paris State entity and
we need to regard them as such